What's happened to LA it kind of, I,
I always thought of LA and even California,
for sure as kind of that hot blonde from high school,
that was always the Belle of the ball.
Didn't have to study very hard phone rang every Friday night for a date really
was able to kind of get by in her looks and kind of cruise.
And now that blonde is 47 years old and not the bell of the ball
anymore. And you know, if you listen to Gavin Newsome that guy,
I've heard interviews with him going, Hey man, where are you going to go?
It's like, it's like the 47 year old blonde saying to the football star.
Hey, don't you want some of this? And it's like, no, nah,
I can find some of that in Texas or Arizona or Nevada
[inaudible].
Hey Rubin. And this is the Rubin report.
Joining me today is a best-selling author,
CoStar of the wonderful documentary,
no safe spaces and host of the Adam Carolla show podcast,
Adam Corolla. Welcome back to the Rubin report.
Always good to be back, Dave. All.
Right, Corolla.
We got a lot to do here because this is my last interview
of 2020. And we said, who can we get on the show to end the year?
That is not completely bananas. And you were on the shortlist.
There were only about two other people and we couldn't get them. So we got you.
You're on the shortlist of Dave Rubin, sane people. How does that make you feel?
You know, when I write my next autobiography,
it's going to be titled from the short bus to the short list.
The Adam Carolla story. Nice to be on the short list. Yeah.
You, you have done it, my friend. All right. First off,
I got to ask you something because there is a rumor going around town. My guys,
my team seemed to believe this rumor that you're moving to Texas. Now,
when I talk about shortlist on my short list of LA people,
I got Adam Corolla. I got Dennis Prager. I got Larry elder,
John Voight. That's it. Are you, are you leaving us? You're going to Houston.
No, not just yet. I did a hit on Tucker Carlson, uh,
I guess last week.
And they brought the van to my house and a
Tucker always does the, when you leave in LA. And I think he, he grew up in,
I think LA and San Diego. So a lot of the guys and,
uh, him and Shapiro are the two when he leave in LA guys because they were in LA
and they, they left and I've always been in LA. So just off the cuff,
because we're in this van, that was a satellite van. I just,
as an improvisational comedian, I just said, Oh, Tucker's hits over.
I'm going to commandeer this van. And I'm driving to Houston.
And for some reason that didn't come across as joke to a lot of people,
but you should have seen that.
It was a joke people because if I was going to Houston,
I would certainly do it on a Southwest flight. I don't think I'm commandeer
$50,000.
Wouldn't take the satellite van from Fox news and drive that all the way to
Texas. You, you do it. First-class on Southwest. I get it.
I feel like just from a mileage standpoint,
it would cost much more to take that satellite van.
All right. So I'm glad to hear it sounds like you're staying for a little bit,
but I did have you over for dinner a couple of months ago.
And you said you were on a three year plan and we're watching Cali
just fall apart. I'm a, I'm a native new Yorker, but I've been here seven years.
You're you're from so Calvin, what the high hell is going on here.
Yeah.
My kids are just getting into high school if you want to call it getting into
high school.
Cause I walked into both their bedrooms this morning and they're both laying in
bed with their covers over them. And I went, Hey, I thought it was school time.
And we're on the zoom class from underneath the comforter.
Um, you know, what's happened to LA it kind of,
I, I always thought of LA and even California,
for sure as kind of that hot blonde from high school,
that was always the Belle of the ball.
Didn't have to study very hard phone rang every Friday night for a date really
was able to kind of get by in or looks and kind of cruise.
And now that blonde is 47 years old and not the Belle of the ball
anymore. And you know, if you listen to Gavin Newsome that guy,
I've heard interviews with him going, Hey man, where are you going to go?
It's like, it's like the 47 year old blonde saying to the, the football star.
Hey don't you want some of this? And it's like, no, nah,
I can find some of that in Texas or Arizona or Nevada or
Nashville, Tennessee or whatever. But there's a kind of a thing where it's like,
when you're used to being the Belle of the ball, you don't study that hard.
You don't try that hard. I mean, California was always like, we got the beaches,
we got the mountains, we got, uh, all we got Disneyland,
we got all this great stuff. So it's like, well,
what about how hospitable you are to business? Well, don't worry about that.
We got Malibu, right.
And what they didn't really factor on. I mean,
there's a few things first off smart people don't want to just hang
out and be essentially abused by their government. That's that's number one,
number two. There's a part of it. That's just practical.
Like I grew up out here, my parents,
my mom had a VW square back. She had like a seventies VW station wagon.
My dad drove a VW bug. Forget about driving to Arizona.
We couldn't get to van IES from North Hollywood without the thing vapor.
And like I talked to a friend of mine,
a Dickey from the Bosstones the lead singer from the band, the Bosstones.
And he was like, yeah, I moved to Arizona and I'm like, Oh, you got to go.
It's like the drive's not bad. I got a great car. It's it's,
it's got Y you know, it's, it's got Sirius XM and uh, in, uh,
a heater in the seat. And it's like, it's, it's not that big though.
Like physically the transportation, you know, the,
the 10 flights a day that are going from Burbank to Phoenix or jet
suite X, you know, like you can get to salt Lake city and, uh, 55 minutes,
like there's a F there's a kind of tangible mechanical part of this,
which is when I was a kid. If you wanted to move,
like buying a ticket on an airline was a big deal.
Like packing up a rider, crock again,
physically didn't have cars that could make it, you know, it's,
it's all kind of doable now.
So, so what do you think the future of this town is?
I think you probably have a couple Hollywood friends that still talk to you.
I've got one or two that would not be happy if I mentioned their name. Um,
but do you think that this town is just now condemned between Garcetti
at the, at the city level and Newsome at the state level?
Do you think we are just truly condemned and now gas gone this new da.
Who's not going to arrest people for prostitution or resisting arrest or a
series of other things. Like how much worse can it get, do you think?
Well, maybe just a little bit. And then maybe it's time. Like, you know,
like a horrible alcoholic, maybe this is the I've stolen.
My kids' piggy bank. I'm going to break it open to buy some malt liquor.
And I now catch a glance of myself in the mirror and I've hit rock
bottom. Maybe that see you in the mirror thing. Maybe we're there.
I was thinking about guests,
Don it's like loitering is not going to be a problem. Trespassing,
not going to be a problem, underage drinking.
It's not going to be a prom prostitution. It's not going to be a problem.
And I thought, where the was this guy? When I was, yeah.
I could have really used this da when I was in high.
Not only that you can steal up to $900. That's what they're telling you.
You can do. So you could steal a PlayStation five and like seven games,
but you go into the eight game range now you're in trouble.
Yeah. It all seems like a very eerie harbinger,
but I hear you. You brought up Hollywood like our Hollywood friends.
Um, if you think about this, uh, Los Angeles,
Hollywood, LA always been the sort of hub of production.
Right. And everything was filmed. Everything.
Every TV show anyone ever saw around the world was filmed and, you know,
Burbank or Culver city or, uh, somewhere in Hollywood.
I mean, I've been on all those,
all the I've been all the I've been all the lots I used to be at Hollywood
center studios doing the man show. And we did crank anchors there.
I did Loveline there.
And at a certain point they started getting greedy.
They started over-regulating. This started over taxing.
And so what did the most liberal people on the planet do?
They started drifting into Atlanta.
They started going to Canada start going to Prague. I mean,
they literally just left. So it was called runaway production.
And at some point,
some semi Schober person thought we can't just have all of this money just
physically leaving the state. And they course corrected a little bit.
They were like, well, why don't we offer some incentives for these businesses,
Hollywood, not to leave the state to do all as,
as I've probably told your audience. Um,
I drove from this studio where I'm sitting right
now. Uh, Bryan Cranston came in and did the show. Brian's a good guy,
probably one of the more liberal guys in Hollywood. And, uh, he said like,
I got to catch an Uber to Burbank, to the Burbank airport. And I said,
I'll drive to the Burbank airport. It's four miles away.
Then we jumped in my car and while we were driving there,
he was explaining that breaking bad was supposed to be filmed out here.
But of course they're going to New Mexico to film.
And of course they lost all that money and all the tourism dollars and all that
kind of stuff. So at some point they kind of wised up and they said,
let's give some incentives for these guys to stay.
And I got to believe at some point,
they're going to try to do that with business.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about comedy,
instead of the nonstop yelling, you get everywhere else,
check out our comedy playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
check out our full episode playlist,
they're both right over here and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.